previously as according to what you've
already said regarding the history of
fasting uh Muslims were commanded to
fast for 3 days and then one
month is this an indication of a
contradiction in the Quran
actually there's no contrad in the
Quran Allah says in the Quran Ina
chapter number four verse number2
do they not consider the Quran with care
do they not ponder over the Quran with
care had it been from anyone besides
Allah there have been many
contradictions so no two vers of the
Quran will ever
contradict but there's something like
abrogation which people differ according
to me abrogation doesn't means
contradiction abrogation means the
verses that were revealed later as Allah
says in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 106 we do not cause any of
the words or ayats of Allah subhana to
be forgotten but we replace it with
something similar or better so many
times when things that were prohibited
or things that were made compos they
came in stages not that was difficult
Made Easy sometimes things difficult
Made Easy sometime things initially Were
Made Easy so people get used to it and
then difficult for example regarding
prohibition of alcohol the first ver to
be revealed was Sur bakar CH 2 vers
number 219 which says that in alcohol in
intoxicants is prophet and loss loss is
more than prophet he didn't say it was
Haram only give a guidance that loss is
more than
Prophet then Surah n 4:43 says that when
you're intoxicated don't offer Salah it
didn't say that if you're not offering
Salah you can have intoxicants if that
word was mentioned then there's a
problem it only said do not be
intoxicated a v offering Salah and since
the Muslims have to offer five time
Salah that means having alcohol intoxic
in the morning without the
question maybe in the evening if you had
by the time you get up in the morning
you become sober the final prohibition
came in
5:9 oh you
believe most certainly intoxicates and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan
handwork abstain from this handwork that
may Prosper so here we come to know that
the ban the prohibition on having
intoxicants alcohol came in
stages it was easy first only gave a
guidance that it's more evil than good
then while praying don't have intoxic
then final B came so similarly for
fasting no two vers of the Quran
contradict though there are some people
who say oh no the Quran now that ver did
not be followed I disagree with that
abrogation doesn't means a contradiction
abrogation means the last verse of Sur
MAA chter 5 vers 9 includes the first
two verses if it's banned overall it's
even banned while offering Salah the
same way here if you read Sur bakar chap
1283 when it was said fasting is
compulsory it did not specify the time
three days that we get from other
sources the Quran doesn't specify it
only says fasting is
f then it says in Surah Bak CH 285 that
you have to fast for the full month of
Ramadan so what was mentioned about
three days every month fasting was
actually from other sources if it was
mentioned in the Quran that you have to
fast for three days and then it says
after that fast for full month then
there's a
contradiction furthermore previously it
was said again in Surah bakar CH 2 184
that you have to fast but those who
cannot fast or those who can fast with
difficulties they have two option either
fast or
feed a person who's poor who's Indigent
so that time it was not f
if it difficult for you to fast yet you
can fast or you can feed a poor person
but fasting is better but not
F now this was for General but afterward
when the ver of Sur bakar CH 25 was
revealed then it became f for everyone
now this verse refers to those people
who are ill terminally ill or they very
elderly people that means mentally they
are fine but physically they cannot fast
in their life if you ill
terminally ill means ill for a long
period and your health may not get fine
or if you're so elderly which you cannot
fast and every year will keep on getting
more and more old so here it says if you
can fast for difficulty find otherwise
feed someone Indigent a poor
person similarly as far as having sexual
intercourse previously the rule was you
should not have sexal intercourse in the
full month of Ramadan with the day or
night but there is not in the Quran the
Quran only says fast in the month of
Ramadan this we get from the other
sources the Quran is not contradicting
it is actually first fasting three days
was in fact
easier then fast if it difficult if you
don't to fast don't fast feed a poor
person so it was easier initially then
later on it became difficult as far as
the approaching your wife initially it
was difficult that you Cann approach the
full month and then Allah made it easy
so no two vers of the Quran contradict
but because the Quran was revealed in a
span of 22 and a half years so many
things that were prohibited came one
shot immediately or it came in stages
many things which were F came
immediately or came in stages so fasting
because initially difficult for the
people it came in stages but
alhamdulillah with all these things no
two verses of the Quran ever contct
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah it seems as
though this is an indication of Allah's
Mercy that he's given
mankind so many opportunities to
implement his uh wonderful way
alhamdulillah